a new bipartisan report from the Senate
Intelligence Committee says Russia
targeted election systems in all 50
states in 2016
more than previously known and it issued
blunt warnings about the 2020 election
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill so Nancy
what else are we learning about from the
report well this is a bipartisan report
Vlad two years in the making and it says
that significant vulnerabilities remain
in the u.s. election system ahead of
2020 this is something that robert
muller
touched on as well at his hearings this
report cited as examples aging voting
equipment paperless machines with no
backup and insecure voter registration
databases Senator Mark Warner who's the
top Democrat on the Intelligence
Committee spoke about some of the ways
to guard against interference on CBS
this morning yesterday
now Senate Democrats did try to push
through more funding for election
security yesterday but the GOP leader
Mitch McConnell blocked that bill he
called it a partisan effort and said
that the Trump administration has
already done a lot to boost election
security Vlad
all right so Nancy president Trump is
also blasting former Special Counsel
Robert Moeller's recent testimony
calling his investigation a coup
Republicans say it's time to move on
from the report but Democrats they're
not ready to give it up yet so what is
their plan well the consensus among
Democrats that we've spoken to flat is
that they need to do more to convince
the American people that impeachment
might be the way to go they don't
believe that the mulher hearings move
the needle very much and so next steps
first investigating the president's
finances particularly any financial ties
to Russia and possibly going to court to
get access to email communications among
White House aides to see if they violate
any record-keeping laws by using private
accounts today Democrats are expected to
take legal action to try to force the
president's former White House Counsel
Don began who do testify about the
president pressuring him to fire the
special counsel Democrats believe that
that was a clear-cut case of obstruction
of justice they want the American people
to hear more about it laughs all right
Nancy thank you very much